bonsoir à tous et bienvenue nous sommes
en direct sur bruit que ce soit on va
parler du corona virus qui sévit depuis
maintenant quelques semaines dans
plusieurs régions du monde et pour en
parler on va être avec l'épidémiologiste
je prononce bien arnaud fontanet qui
était avec dont sort à vous ça j'ai moi
d'abord vous poser cette première
question en même temps qu'on salue les
personnes qui nous regardent
actuellement on vient d'apprendre qu'il
y avait trois nouveaux morts en italie
même quatre maintenant dépassé de 7 à 11
victimes
deux nouveaux cas de grippe à virus dont
l'un à paris très franchement est ce que
nous en tant que français on doit avoir
peur de ce virus alors je pense que les
minimes i est passé depuis la semaine
dernière dans une nouvelle phase
jusqu'à présent c'était quelque chose
qui était finalement assez lointain il y
avait un foyer majeur en chine qui
avaient été à l'occasion de quelques
introductions en france il ya eu jusqu'à
douze patients en france depuis à peu
près un mois et demi mais c'étaient des
introductions isolé sophie soir des
contamines où il ya eu cinq patients
identifiés d'un coup et finalement on
arrivait à bien contrôler les choses
ce qui a changé depuis la semaine
dernière c'est qu'il ya maintenant des
foyers très important dans des pays
comme corée du sud qui doit être pas
loin de 900 cas le japon singapour il ya
l'iran
et puis plus récemment l'italie et
l'italie là on est déjà 300 cas et on
peut s'attendre dans les semaines qui
viennent à des introductions répétées du
virus qui nous viendront de l'ensemble
de ces pays et puis d'autres pays qui
pourrait toucher entre temps donc ce
sera plus simplement des personnes qui
arrivent de chine qui peuvent amener
virus qui faisait que jusqu'à présent le
diagnostic était finalement assez facile
puisque quand on avait des symptômes et
qu'on arrive et chine on pense comme un
virus maintenant c'est des gens qui vont
venir
possiblement d'un peu partout dans le
monde qui vont être infectées par ce
vocable un virus et qui peuvent
introduire le virus en france
et inévitablement il ya des chaînes on
devra identifier tout de suite et s'est
enlevée la transmission et puis d'autres
où le virus à se transmettre un peu plus
avec des foyers un peu plus grand donc
je m'attends dans les semaines qui
viennent à ce qu'on ait des éclosions de
cas en france sur le territoire français
de plus en plus fréquente pour lesquels
il faudra agir immédiatement
mais avec quelques fois un peu de retard
et deux conditions difficiles alors
concrètement 5 depuis le début de cette
épidémie s'était concentrée sur la chine
mais on voit donc depuis quelques jours
que ça c'est ça se passait pendant
d'autres d'autres régions du monde sait
ça où il ya une inquiétude justement sur
une perte de contrôle quelque part des
événements alors disons il y avait déjà
plusieurs foyers qui s'est allumé dans
pas mal de pays
finalement depuis la mi-janvier même
mais ces foyers sont devenus vraiment
plus actif j'ai envie de dire
dans la semaine qui vient de s'écouler
l'épidémie s'est vraiment emballée en
corée par exemple on est passé de 200 à
900 cas dans la semaine et donc ça c'est
nouveau foyer ils sont capables d
s'aimer et de nous toucher
bon après il faut raisonner de façon
internationale à la question est plus
tellement de savoir d'où va venir le
virus et qui va nous l'envoyer ça c'est
plus la question la question c'est est
ce qu'on est capable sur le sol français
de gérer ces introductions virus parce
que ces scènes très pour ce qu'on va
apporter qui déterminera l'ampleur de
l'épidémie en france si on devait vivre
une épidémie alors je dis bonsoir à tous
parce que vous êtes donc
regardez actuellement sur ce live et
j'invite toutes celles et ceux qui nous
regardent à poser des questions dans les
commentaires
l'idée c'est de faire un live interactif
et aussi un peu bas voilà pédagogique on
parle beaucoup justement du coronavirus
c'est de poser des questions avec
quelqu'un qui s'y connaît qui peut
répondre aussi à vos questions donc
n'hésitez pas à partager ce direct pour
informer tout le monde mais aussi avec
vos questions dans les commentaires
mais certaines aussi qu'ils sont déjà
revenus parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
diffusé hier plusieurs discours
notamment celui du ministre de la santé
olivier 0 est-ce qu'on nous cache des
trucs
voilà la question qui revient
régulièrement est ce qu'on nous cache
des choses est ce que il y aurait cette
idée de se dire qu'on ne dirait pas tout
pour ne pas affoler les populations
parce qu'on sait que c'est vrai que ça
s'emballe beaucoup ces derniers jours
surtout depuis l'arrivée du virus en
italie pour la france est ce que pour
vous on a vraiment un contrôle parfait
en matière de communication
en france en tout cas des quais des
nouveaux cas ils sont immédiatement
déclaré vous avez vu la rapidité avec
laquelle il a à chaque fois une un point
presse du ministère de la santé où ils
viennent nous dire nouveaux cas en
france et c'est donc non je pense pas
que nous cache des choses ce qui est
très difficile c'est de dire où cette
épidémie va aller là je parle à
l'échelle mondiale parce que ce virus on
ne connaît que depuis très peu de temps
finalement réfléchissez rappelez vous
que les premiers cas ont eu lieu dans la
première quinzaine de décembre dans la
ville de wuhan en chine et on est à
peine trois mois plus tard on sait déjà
qu'il s'agit d'un nouveau virus qui
n'avait jamais été identifiée auparavant
on se doute qu'ils aient un animal qui
l'a transmis à l'homme dans les marchés
de morale
et puis deux puis on essaye de
recueillir un maximum d'informations
pour savoir d'une part quand se transmet
ce nouveau virus et d'autres parqués sur
les conséquences chez les individus qui
sont affectés et tout ce savoir ils
s'accumulent sur l'espace de quelques
semaines
c'est encore un phénomène très très
récent et du coup il ya des points
d'interrogation parce que évidemment
on n'a pas encore fait le tour de la
question et compris tout ce que vous
pourrez savoir sur ce nouveau virus
alors justement parlant de ce virus non
à cette question de gus boursiers dans
les commentaires qu'on salue qui nous
demandaient ce que le grenat virus n'est
pas moins dangereux que la grippe
hivernale c'est vrai qu'on veut parfois
faire des comparaisons en termes de sur
ce virus sur sa mortalité est ce qu on a
des indications aujourd'hui qui permet
de comparer avec d'autres virus est déjà
existants il ya deux choses
il ya d'une part et ce qu'il est plus ou
moins transmissibles et puis d'autre
part est ce qu'il est plus ou moins
virulent donc la première question c'est
combien de personnes vont être touchés
la deuxième c'est parmi les personnes
touchées combien vont éventuellement
faire des formes sévères ou décédés
alors sur la première question
on sait que c'est un virus qui se
transmet comme la grille comme le sera
ce aussi inquiété son cousin qui était
sorti en 2003 du sud est de la chine et
qui avait aussi fait le tour du monde ou
en gros chaque personne va l'affecter
deux ou trois toute la difficulté après
c'est de savoir est ce que on est
capable de stopper ce virus un il est
transmissible certes ça c'est deux ou
trois c'est quand vous avez aucune
mesure pour essayer de le bloquer mais
si vous mettez en place des mesures pour
le bloquer et ce qu'elles vont marcher
pour le strass savez très bien marché et
pourquoi savez très bien marché aux deux
caractéristiques essentielles du camp à
virus du strass la première c'est que la
maladie n'était contagieuse que trois à
quinze jours après le début des
symptômes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est que
quand quelqu'un était malade on avait
deux à trois jours pour isoler cette
personne avant elle et contaminer
d'autres personnes
et du coup il n'y avait pas de
transmission secondaire la deuxième
caractéristique avait rendu le strass
facile à contrôler c'est que toutes les
malades faisaient des formes sévères
pour les repérer il était hospitalisé
et et on laissait pas passer des cas
donc on pouvait couper les chaînes de
transmission avec son nouveau copain un
virus ces paramètres malheureusement ne
sont pas les mêmes ce qu'on a appris
depuis mais qu'on ne sait que depuis
très récemment
c'est que la transmission et débute dès
le début des symptômes
ça veut dire que à peine vous êtes
malade vous avez déjà contagieux et le
temps qu'il faut pour faire le
diagnostic qui vous isolez vous aurez
contaminer d'autres personnes
et puis deuxième chose il ya des gens
qui font des formes très mineur de la
maladie mais qui pourraient être
contagieux ils diront même pas consulté
et pourtant ils seront affectés d'autres
personnes donc vous voyez bien que ces
deux caractéristiques ce virus va être
beaucoup plus difficile à contrôler si
je prends juste pour finir avec 20 ans
de la griffe bas la grippe c'est un
virus qui est aussi très transmissible
qu'on ne peut pas arrêter et qui
effectivement va donner toute forme de
forme bénigne jusqu'à des formes sévères
et aujourd'hui ce nouveau corps à des
virus on commence à se dire qu'ils se
comportent plus comme une grippe que
comme à coronavirus du strass pondéré
connu il ya 17 ans alors on a pas mal de
questions dans les commentaires dont une
qui revient beaucoup je pourrais pas si
tu es prêt n'ont tellement rien d'acquis
de personnes qui l'ont posée c'est
qu'elles seront finalement les premiers
symptômes qu'on peut ressentir quand on
a recours aux navires us alors ça se
manifeste comme toute affection
respiratoire
ça peut être des choses relativement
bénigne mais pour ceux qui vont évoluer
rappeneau mathy qui est la forme la plus
classique
on est comme avec une grippe au tout
début le premier jour vous allez me
sentir un peu fatigué vous allez avoir
un peu mal partout
douleurs musculaires et fatigue et
éventuellement un peu de fièvre
et puis le lendemain la fièvre se
déclarent assez rapidement vous avez
into two qu'on appelle ses chats vous
crachez pas vous avez tous de tous et là
comme ça tout d'irritation un peu et
puis quelques jours plus tard pour ceux
qui évoluent sur des formes graves
vous allez très souffler ça c'est le
signe que la prime au dj importante donc
ça c'est des signes typiques de la
fiction par ce nouveau grand navire
russe après vous me direz 1 c'est là
juste une grippe donc ne soyez pas
inquiet si vous avez ces symptômes là
mais beaucoup plus de chances d'avoir
une épine griffe
on est en pleine épidémie de grippe
actuellement et puis à d'autres virus
respiratoires qui circulent en hiver
préférentiellement qui donne les mêmes
symptômes
donc voilà pour l'instant le corps d'un
virus y circulent
j'ai envie de dire aux gens vous aurait
dit il ya deux heures ici redus pas sur
le territoire français on vient
d'apprendre qu'il ya deux cas qui vient
d'être diagnostiqué donc on sait
maintenant qui circulent mais ça reste
extrêmement peu importants le virus qui
circule aujourd'hui c'est le virus de la
grippe si vous êtes malade c'est la
grippe plutôt que autre chose du coup
des personnes qui ressentiraient ces
symptômes dont on convient d'évoquer
qu'est ce qu'elles doivent faire
est-ce qu'il faut qu'ils aillent aux
urgences ou contraints à rester à leur
domicile et attendre que les services
spécialisés viennent comment ça se passe
en fait vous allez pas la question c'est
de savoir est-ce que vous et
éventuellement ce nouveau corps d'un
virus alors qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qui
nous aide pour faire la part des choses
entre eux est ce que ce serait une
grippe ou une chose jusqu'à très
récemment la principale notion qui nous
aide dans cette démarche diagnostique
c'était est-ce que vous avez été
récemment en chine dans les 14 derniers
jours
on vient de rajouter d'autres pays sur
la liste parce qu'on se rencontre qui a
maintenant d'autres pays où le virus
circule beaucoup et ses autres pays
c'est singapour ou la corée du sud
et puis très récemment cédé les
provinces du nord de l'italie puisque
depuis ce week-end on sait qu'il ya
foyer actif en lombardie et en vénétie
donc si dans les 14 jours d'un retour de
chine singapour corée du sud ou des
provinces du nord de l'italie
vous avez ces symptômes là vous faites
le 15 vous n'avez pas aux urgences vous
n'allez pas voir votre médecin traitant
parce qu'il faudrait pas infecter
d'autres personnes si vous étiez vous
même malade de ce nouveau corps d'un
virus vous faites le 15 vous discuté au
téléphone avec le régulateur du samu qui
va vous poser d'autres questions pour
s'assurer que vous avez vraiment des
symptômes qui sont objectifs et puis
décider si oui ou non il faut vous
envoyer dans un hôpital spécialisé vous
serez mis en isolement ofra le test
diagnostique et au décidera de vous
garder en isolement si vous avez ce
nouveau coronavirus ou alors ne vous
traitez comme une grippe classique si
vous n'êtes pas atteints de ce nouveau
corps d'un virus l'autre des ongs ypres
et vous faire penser vous avez ce
nouveau corps d'un virus c'est si vous
avez été en contact là encore dans les
14 jours précédents avec une personne
qui a été diagnostiqué avec ce nouveau
grand d'un virus et si c'est le cas à ce
moment là même démarche
on fait le 15 on va aux urgences on va
pas voir son médecin traitant on fait le
gaz et on discute avec le régulateur
donc voilà aujourd'hui un petit peu les
conduites à tenir qui sont recommandées
pour des personnes qui se poseraient la
question alors il ya aussi un numéro
vert que je connais par coeur mais vous
trouverez sur le site de mystères de la
santé ou ailleurs si vous avez des
questions à poser un si vous les
questions à poser à pelé pas le 15
ils sont vraiment beaucoup de choses à
faire sur la régulation des urgences
donc c'est pas à eux qu'il faut poser
des questions mais allez faire ce numéro
vert que vous trouverez sur les i du
ministère de la santé et poser vos
questions alors il ya la question qui se
pose ici sur les mesures d'hygiène à
prendre au quotidien on va dire ce qu'on
appelle le vivre ensemble
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire vous savez
plus clément il ya dix gestes du
quotidien mieux fait alors vraiment en
période hivernale
russ respiratoires je vous rappelle la
façon avec laquelle vous devez tous et
vous tousser dans le pli du coude c'est
pas très pratique je suis d'accord avec
vous pas forcément très vivant et a en
tous genres pic du coude
pourquoi pas contaminée pour la si vous
avez des mouchoirs on dit lucie mouchoir
à usage unique lors pas très facile
parce que vous imaginez qui est quand
même beaucoup d'allers retours mais
voilà faut pas avoir un mouchoir qui
vous sert et resserre et resserre et qui
deviendrait une source de contagion pour
l'environnement et puis lavez vous les
mains très régulièrement ça vous aidera
pour les affections respiratoires mais
ça vous aidera aussi pour les
gastronomes voudra pour beaucoup de
choses et déjà ça c'est une mesure que
vous pouvez faire et j'ai envie de dire
même s'est encore un virus un pour votre
vie quotidienne c'est des mesures
d'hygiène qui vous rendre la vie plus
facile et vous protégeront de beaucoup
d'affections respiratoires et
d'infection gastro-intestinale alors on
parle beaucoup des mesures de
confinement qui sont mis en place dans
les pays touchés actuellement
imaginons on a la même situation qu'en
italie qui arrive en france sur un foyer
mais imprécis comment ça se passe au
niveau des mesures de confinement
commence à s'organiser ce que tout et
même que reese est ce que les gens
peuvent sortir comment ça se passe alors
là en fait ce sont des choses qu'on n'a
pas encore beaucoup de texter riences
dans la dans leur mise en place parce
que finalement ces mesures de
quarantaine et où on les a pas utilisés
depuis la grippe espagnole
ça nous ramène s'entend en avant c'était
1918 1919
c'est pour vous dire que vraiment ça
fait très longtemps qu'on n'a pas eu à
utiliser ces mesures là alors les
mesures de confinement
elles auront un impact si on arrive à
agir très tôt au moment le foyer est
tout juste débutants on sait qu'il ya
pas de kayes et à ce moment là de
effectivement ou confinées la population
sur un espace réduit en leur disant de
rester chez eux et tous pendant que ça
passe va aider à empêcher la propagation
de là si malheureusement le virus est
déjà parti ailleurs parce que les gens
avaient bougé avant même que vous
installez vos mesures de confinement
vous allez avoir peu d'impact alors
l'idée c'est quand même d'essayer de
ralentir la progression de l'épidémie
c'est important parce que le fait de
râles
la provision des milles et mis ça fait
qu'il n'a pas de pic un soudain qui fait
qui lui sera très difficile à gérer nous
ne serait ce que pour pouvoir
hospitalisés les gens dans des bonnes
conditions et c'est bon mais là les
mesures de confinement c'est une chose
il y aura d'autres
d'autres mesures qui pourraient arriver
un peu intermédiaire je dirais on a dit
déjà les mesures d'hygiène classique ça
vous voulez commencer aujourd'hui et le
faire de temps avec ou sans corde un
virus les mesures qui pourraient être
plus rapidement mise en place s'il y
avait une circulation du virus important
dans un endroit ce serait dire éviter
les lieux publics on pouvait être amené
à vous dire éviter des bars des
restaurants on peut fermer les cinémas
tous les endroits de rassemblement parce
que là il ya des risques de transmission
et c'est pas si pénalisant votre vie
quotidienne c'est pas drôle de vous dire
vous avez pas voir les dans la marde
resto où elle a aussi un jeu pendant
quelques temps mais c'est pas non plus
un truc vraiment très difficile plus
compliqué ça va aider mesure de dire à
des personnes vous pouvez plus sortir de
chez vous et c'est n'est pas encore ça a
été utilisée en chine dans l'épicentre
de l'épidémie au moment où l'épidémie
vraiment battait son plein bras vu des
images assez incroyable d'une ville
tente avec desjardins on n'y est pas et
sa seule chose qu'ils arriveraient
vraiment en dernier recours et puis
aussi le fait après de fermer une
commune est de dire aux gens vous en
sortez plus vous entendrez plus bas une
fois de plus je les dis c'est utile si
vous le faites très très tôt mais si les
gens ont déjà eu l'occasion de sortir
alors vous n'allez pas aller très loin
avec un séquel beaucoup de commentaires
et beaucoup de questions qui ont été
posées là dessus c'est l'actualité
sportive demain il ya le match lyon je
veux tu
justement serait attendu juste - lyon 3
mille supporters italiens est ce qu'il
ya un risque particulier par rapport à
ça ou est ce que finalement il faut pas
avoir des psychoses particulière dans
ces questions que je poserais de façon
plus générale sur des événements à venir
des deux trois prochains mois
comment est-ce qu'on va les gérer alors
là c'est vraiment
c'est des questions extrêmement
difficile yann je pense qu'une espèce de
d'évaluation du risque à faire à la
première question qu'il faut se poser
c'est est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
est un événement absolument
indispensable ou est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui peut être reporté à
plus tard quand je vais pas commenter
sur un match de la ligue des champions
il y aura les avis vont être très
partagés sur le caractère indispensable
ou pas mais je plutôt parler de
l'événement professionnel
est ce que ce serait plutôt sain se rend
de dire voilà donc le match vous
pourquoi pas mais que les supporters ne
viennent pas parce que trois mille
personnes pourraient être
potentiellement est ce que ce sera une
mesure aisément de d'où viendraient ces
supportait et s'ils viennent une région
qui est réellement très nord j'ai parlé
de jeu durant on peut dire mon maître de
valeur des gones dans le nord de
l'italie
le série de virus circule au nord de
l'italie c'est une vraie question qui se
pose
mais moi je pense à tout événement par
exemple marathon paris alain baraton
paris début avril
vous avez des gens qui viennent du monde
entier ils vont être est entassé vous
avez vu la densité humaine qui a pendant
le marathon tout le monde crache par
terre parce que bon bah quand on respire
on a beaucoup on a besoin de cracher par
terre et et ça c'est un événement où je
crois la question va vraiment se poser
parce que nos sentiments
séguéla dans les semaines qui viennent
on va se retrouver avec des
introductions de plus en plus fréquente
du virus sur le territoire français il
ya des moments où on arrivera et
immédiatement détecté les patients les
isoler ça ira pas plus loin
bientôt moment où a détecté un peu plus
tard là on aura des petits foyers
débutants et ça va être difficile à
gérer et il faut s'habituer sur les
semaines qui vont viennent à se dire que
l'on va devoir gérer ces situations et
là des événements vous faites venir des
personnes du monde entier pour se
retrouver ensemble en espace plus ou
moins confiné sur une période courte
je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre
qu'on va être amené à reporter parce que
voilà ça va pas être c'est pas le moment
de le faire chez lui toutes les
personnes qui nous regardent
actuellement en ile et 20h46 et on se
retrouve donc avec l'épidémiologiste
arnaud fontanet qui avec nous pour
répondre à mes questions mais aussi les
vôtres vous êtes très nombreux à poser
des questions n'hésitez pas à continuer
à le faire et à partager ce direct il ya
une question qui se pose beaucoup
actuellement et qu'on voit beaucoup dans
les commentaires c'est est ce qu'on a un
traitement efficace aujourd'hui un
vaccin quelque chose qui permettrait de
dire bon on sait comment lutter contre
le courant et de virus malheureusement
non il n'y a pas de traitement
aujourd'hui qui marche contre ce nouveau
corps d'un virus il ya des traitements
qui sont nécessaires en fait c'est pas
des faire un traitement s'apprend sur un
nouveau virus puisque ça virus je
rappelle qu'on connaît seulement depuis
trois mois
même pas mais faire un nouveau
traitement c'est quelque chose qui prend
au minimum à deux ans en revanche que
pour faire c'est ce qu'on a commencé
c'est utiliser des molécules des
traitements qui sont efficaces contre
d'autres virus en six ans tient
peut-être que ça pourrait marcher contre
ce nouveau coronavirus parce que après
tout ça reste un virus et c'est ce qui
est en train d'être fait ok des
traitements du sida qui sont testés et
des traitements qui avait été utilisée
contre et voilà qui est traitement qui
ont été utilisés comme beaucoup de
maladies virales pour notre intensité
pour voir est-ce que ça a un effet on
aura les résultats dans un
moi je suis pas particulièrement
optimiste parce que c'est pas des
traitements qui avait été fait pour ce
nouveau corps d'un virus mais on peut
avoir une bonne surprise
et si c'est une bonne surprise c'est
parce que le traitement étant déjà connu
il est disponible
il suffit de produire en plus grande
quantité on sait à qui on veut
l'administré inquiet on connaît les
effets indésirables des traitements donc
ce serait une solution rapide et facile
ça c'est ce qu'on apprendra dans assez
vite si malheureusement aucun de ces
traitements ne fonctionne et bien là on
partira sur une course qui sera plus
long où on va essayer de vraiment créer
des nouveaux traitements spécifiques de
ce virus et ça ça peut prendre vraiment
plusieurs mois et on sera réduit à faire
ce qu'on appelle un traitement
symptomatique
c'est bien on va vous traiter votre fiel
on peut traiter les douleurs et puis si
vous avez du mal à respirer on vous met
l'oxygène et puis après éventuellement
pour les quelques personnes qui auront
besoin
il y aura une réanimation avec une
intubation une ventilation mais bon
voilà ça c'est ce qu'on appelle un
traitement symptomatique ça ne s'attaque
pas directement qui réussit on à l'hiver
les commentaires justement qu'il dit est
ce que le temps de trouver justement
tête ce vaccin ou autre le virus ne
risque pas de muter ce cas pas un risque
alors servi russe qui mute cd virus qui
font des c virus là ils ont bâti système
de réparation donc quand il se confie et
bien ils font pas mal de d'erreur de
copies c'est ce qu'on appelle des
mutations
ça arrive de façon complètement
aléatoire c'est pas du tout le virus qui
est intelligent et qui se dit comment je
vais changer pour mieux affecter en
revanche quand il fait une erreur et que
cette erreur elle rend plus fort par
rapport aux autres virus
eh ben c'est ce nouveau virus qui va
s'imposer par rapport aux autres c'est
comme ça que les mutations du virus
mutant vous remplacez les virus qu'il y
avait au départ affectés et celui là il
est connu pour être capable de muter
comme tous les autres virus qui comme
lui soit arn à la rn c'est une des
formes du jeune homme alors le
aujourd'hui on le surveille de très près
et il ya des sites pour ceux d'entre
vous que ça intéresse vous pouvez aller
vous tapez next next20 nsdr à y aide
pour un port goberger ne mettra le lien
dans les commentaires pour souhaiter
aller dessus vous regardez ils vous
aident à voir la carte tous les virus
qui ont été déjà séquencés et vous
verrez qu on compte le nombre de
mutations qui les différencie un
tutorial qui est très bien fait pour
vous apprendre à interpréter et vous
regarderez comme ça comment est ce qu'on
arrive à suivre les virus sur l'ensemble
de la planète a regardé les mutations à
les compter et c'est ce qu'on fait parce
qu'on me demande si effectivement ce
virus a muté
alors il ya une question qui se pose
beaucoup dans les commentaires c'est se
dire qu'on analyse on voit que l'âge des
personnes qui décèdent de ce virus est
souvent très âgées ou des personnes même
parfois qui sont parfois déjà malades
d'autres d'autres choses comment on
explique qu'une personne plus âgée peut
être plus fragiles face à ceux en
précisant seulement que les personnes
âgées comme vous le dites à sont plus
fragiles
et puis surtout si l'on l'hypertension
du diabète ils vont être plus vulnérable
alors ça se voyait aussi l'état gris et
la 80 % de tous les gens qui décèdent
80% au plus 60 ans avec ce virus mais ça
veut aussi dire que 20 % moins de 60 ans
et ça c'est beaucoup parce que des
jeunes de moins de 60 ans qui meurent
jeudi jeunes de moins de 60 ans que j'ai
59 ans donc j'en profite
mais c'est c'est quelque chose qui est
évidemment vécu plus mal parce que c'est
des chefs de famille etc et compagnie
des gens qui sont très actifs alors une
relative bonne nouvelle c'est que les
enfants ne font pas la maladie et les
jeunes adolescents et c'est aussi sont
quand même préservé
on voit rarement des formes graves avant
l'âge de 25 30 ans mais ces voix là
c'est un virus quand même qui va parmi
les décès vous trouverez quand même 20%
dès gens qui ont moins de 60 ans et ça
ça pèsera lourd à la fin on a vu dans
les pharmacies que les masques
respiratoires étaient parfois dévalisé
essais remontent parfois même à quelques
semaines est-ce que c'est utile dans l'
acheter un et si oui quel type de masque
faut-il porter lors ya deux types de
masse pour deux utilisations différentes
le masque on appelle chirurgicale qui a
peur papier le plus simple il sera utile
pour celui qui est malade pour protéger
son environnement
et ça c'est quand vous apprenez que va
vous revenez de chine vous êtes en
isolement quarantaine chez vous vous
vous surveillez votre température deux
fois par jour vous avez la fièvre va si
vous avez la fièvre vous appelez le 15
on les dit tout à l'heure mais aussi
vous mettez votre masque pour protéger
votre environnement et l'autre masque
que l'on appelle ffp2 qui tamas que
celui qui vous donne un peu bête de
canard beaucoup plus ému et c est bien
ce masque là c'est celui que vous vous
utiliserez pour vous protéger des autres
alors fait c'est pas vous qui allez
utiliser d'abord c'est les personnels
soignants c'est ceux qui sont au contact
des patients il veut se protéger
il met ce type de masque pour vous la
seule utilité de ce masque ce serait si
au passé en mode épidémique a donc si
vraiment il met circulation intense du
virus dans l'endroit où vous vivez et
que vous vous devez sortir et être au
contact de gens de façon assez rapproché
à ce moment-là ce mas pourrait vous être
utile mais pour l'instant il n'a aucune
légitimité parce que le virus circule en
france
il circule très très peu on sait que
pour l'instant africains peu de cas
jusqu'à maintenant il ya en egypte on
apprend à l'instant et c'est une
information je vous donne qui a un cas
qui étaient c'est un peu d'informations
directes ans
en algérie on l'apprend d'une personne
qui venait d'italie c1 on peut penser à
l'afrique parce qu'on a les craintes
peut-être que certains pays soient pas
protégés peut-être comme d'autres et
bien c'est dire que le contrôle de
l'épidémie serait beaucoup plus
difficile sur des pays qui ont des
systèmes de santé plus fragile donc
l'afrique en feraient partie si le virus
arrivé sur des grosses capitale comme
lagos comme abidjan comme nairobi où
addis abeba le potentiel de transmission
est quand même très fort alors
aujourd'hui en dehors de l'egypte et je
l'apprends de l'algérie il n'ya pas
effectivement d'autres cas qui était
diagnostiquée le mois qui vient de
s'écouler il a été vraiment utilisé pour
essayer de préparer des laboratoires
dans les capitales africaines pour le
diagnostic
maintenant c'est un laboratoire pour
quelquefois des grandes capitales ça va
être très difficile si le virus arrive
dans la période où on est aujourd'hui il
ya très peu de suspicion de cas et c'est
gérable ça pourrait devenir plus
difficile si le virus mais a circulé
très largement dans le monde et où les
introductions deviendrait beaucoup plus
fréquents sur des pays africains qui on
le sait on au coût de contacts avec la
chine maintenant mais aussi avec le
reste du monde puisque le virus il en
train vraiment de sortir de la chine et
s'installer dans beaucoup d'autres pays
et là on peut craindre si le virus il
arrive qu'il sera beaucoup plus
difficile de contrôler on parle beaucoup
de la durée d'incubation parce que c'est
cela qui est aussi important pour
détecter ces casques est ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui une estimation précise de la
durée d'incubation de ce virus ou alors
elle estimé autour de six jours
peut-être un peu moins cinq jours et ça
c'est la moyenne après ce qui nous
intéresse nous c'est qu'il est la durée
accusation maximale pourquoi parce que
quand on met des gens en isolement
on va les garder en isolement en
quarantaine si l'on était contact d'un
patient par exemple le temps la durée
d'incubation maximale pour voir si
pendant cette période ils vont
développer la maladie
si après cette durée d'incubation
maximale que l'on fixe à 14 joue
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas développer
la maladie
alors vous avez été en contact avec un
patient c'est que vous n'allez pas être
malade 1 14 jours c'est suffisant pour
le savoir puisque c'est la durée
d'incubation dit maximale donc voilà on
est fixé sur ce 14 jours qu'on avait des
piles des bus toutes les estimations
qu'on a depuis convergent pour ne dire
que six jours c'est la moyenne et que
douze jours ce serait le maximum alors
il ya eu deux trois exemples qui n'ont
pas pu être vérifiées ou on a 10 24 ou
27 jours mais ça reste exceptionnel
et puis on va pas changer cette règle
pour deux ou trois cas très rares parce
que déjà quatorze jours en quarantaine
c'est pas drôle et pour les services
sanitaires qui doit faire le suivi c'est
beaucoup de boulot alors on appelle
l'information de la soirée c'est qu'à de
nouveaux cadres qu un virus qui ont été
détectés en france
la question c'est aussi dans la
détection justement par rapport à la
durée d'incubation est ce que
techniquement parce qu'on sait que les
boubous dallaire de personnes qui ont
été testées je pense par exemple hier
donc commissariat du xiiie
arrondissement à paris
il ya plusieurs personnes qui étaient
suspectés d'avoir le coronavirus
touristes asiatiques étaient passés par
l'italie est elle était peut-être passé
là bas il ya quelques jours
est ce que c'est possible qu'une
personne soit révélée négative au bout
de trois quatre jours et que finalement
la durée d'incubation fait qu'on peut
l'attester positive au bout de huit ou
dix jours alors imaginons quelqu'un
était en contact avec un patient si vous
allez lui faire le test le lendemain il
va négatif ces sept personnes attendent
incubation la maladie va déclarer on va
dire en moyenne six jours après
vous trouverez peut-être le vivre dans
sa gorge 4 5 jours après mais les trois
premiers jours il n'y a rien donc après
juste avant le début des symptômes ou
trouve qu'on se trouvait virus dans la
gorge ça va durer pendant toute la durée
des symptômes la quantité de virus
helvètes maximale au début de la maladie
puis elle va s'amenuiser et quant au
bout d'une semaine à personne va guérir
ben vous retrouverez peut-être sur le
virus dans la gorge un ou deux jours
après la fin des symptômes
et puis il disparaîtra donc si vous
testez avant ou après vous allez rien
trouvé du coup c'est un peu ça peut
expliquer que des personnes seraient
négatives et comprend et contrôlée
positive à presque sans ajustement plus
compliqué cette détection sert de se
dire que je peux garder des personnes
passent à travers des mailles du filet
mais c'est le risque lorsque nous dit
aujourd'hui c'est que l'on peut attester
que les personnes qui ont des symptômes
c'est à dire que si vous êtes en
quarantaine parce que vous avez un
contact avec un patient ou parce que
vous devez d'une région où le virus
circule on va pas voter c'est simba
systématiquement tous les jours on
attend de voir le virus arrivé parce que
c'est l'état ce qui sont difficiles à
faire qui sont plutôt eux qui prennent
du temps etc
en revanche on vous dit vous surveillez
vos température et si vous avez une
fièvre alors là oui on viendra vous
tester alors on sait que des mesures qui
ont été prises notamment pour les jeunes
enfants qui reviennent des zones
touchées
pourquoi 14 jours pourquoi on fait pour
les enfants et pas pour les adultes
on sait pour l'instant ces
recommandations ont été émises par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale n'a
pas été forcément aussi donné d'un point
les professionnels figurent par exemple
quelqu'un qui aurait 30 en cinq ans
qu'ils travailleraient kg il n'y a pas
la même comment ça se fait qu'il ya une
différence de traitement ou est-ce que
vous
pour ça que c'est une erreur frêche va
alors quatorze jours c'est toujours la
même chose c'est la durée d'activation
maximale si les enfants on va développer
la maladie oui 14 jours ils vont pas à
développer après donc ils peuvent
retourner à leurs occupations
habituelles
pourquoi les enfants parce qu'on sait
que pour la grippe par exemple les
écoles c'est un endroit fabuleux pour la
transmission de la grippe
les enfants vous savez ils sont 20 ème
tous dans des classes qui sont pas de
taille forcément très grande ils sont
très nombreux il joue au foot ensemble
ils sont toujours très proches les uns
des autres et puis du coup ils se
transmettent facilement les virus
respiratoires et c'est pour ça que dans
la petite enfance vous l'avez tournée a
tous vécu un des gamins ils sont
toujours un peu malade ils ont toujours
un peu de tout petit quelque chose et
caetera et puis les jeunes parents aussi
avec mes des enfants voilà par leur
activité par la fréquence de leurs
contacts par la proximité de leurs
contacts
ils vont se transmettre des virus
respiratoires beaucoup plus facilement
et c'est pour ça que l'on a dit les
enfants qui reviennent de zones à risque
et bien il vaut mieux qu'ils restent
chez eux pendant pendant 14 jours
alors les adultes on pense qu'ils ont
des comportements un peu différent ils
sont quand même pas tous à l'utilisation
les autres en train de jouer comme nous
pour de récréation enfin dans la plupart
des boulots de telles que je connais et
du goût on leur dit de d'agir de façon
responsable et selon la nature du
travail qu'ils ont ce qu'ils peuvent
faire du télétravail mais ils vont le
faire
ceux qui doivent aller au boulot il faut
y aller mais alors on leur dira des
transports en commun et tenez vous à
l'écart éviter d'être trop proche de vos
collègues garder un peu de distance et
céréales sert à nourrir leur demande
d'avoir un comportement responsable et
on sait que pour un enfant pas les mêmes
recommandations valent et faire ainsi un
gamin il arrive dans une cour de
récréation ne vais pas lui dire vous
êtes tous à trois mètres les uns des
autres en piqué dans les cours de
récréation pendant la récréation ça
marchera pas donc voilà c'est pour ça
qu'il ya différence de traitement entre
enfants et adultes et beaucoup de
questions sur l'origine du virus de se
dire comment et le typhus créé qu'en ont
ils pu se répand certains appareils de
la voie à limeuil d'autres ont parlé
jusqu'à d'ailleurs ce serait dans un
laboratoire que ça s'est passé
qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre à ça
aujourd'hui on sait bien aujourd'hui
d'où viennent les virus ce sont des
virus qui sont
qui nous arrive de dumont dany massé
émergents cinq ans je prends ce sera
sans penser à imola on parle de six cas
on prend tous ces virus
ces virus qui vivent d'avoir chez
l'animal et puis qui un jour ils vont
passer chez donne alors il le passage
chez l'homme il peut se faire dans des
contacts étroits entre les animaux et
les hommes
ça peut être quelquefois pour des virus
qui sont transmis par des grands singes
par exemple quand on va chasser ces
grands singes et puis qu'on découpe la
viande est bien là le sens qui est
affectée peut affecter des zones qui
vont ramener la maladie
c'est ce qui a dû se passer un jour pour
les yeux rougis sida c'est ce qui se
passe avec des virus et voilà là avec
ses coronavirus pour le sras en 2003 on
n'avait retrouvé que c'était si vaine si
les petits carnivores qui essaient
d'échapper au museau pointu qui était
consommée dans des restaurants de caen
dont un fugace de la chine qui était
affecté avec ce corps d'un virus et qui
ont affecté les clients ou les cuisines
restants il est affecté quand il était
vivant à parce qu'ils étaient dans des
cages vivant à l'entrée du restaurant
parce que les clients ils voulaient
manger un animal fera ils veulent être
sûrs dont qu'ils arrivaient dans la cage
jeune homme dans le restaurant y avait
là cachées regard des idées moi je
mangeais cette civette le cuisinier la
rive
il prend la civette hydromel la civette
qui sont qui ajuste qui était passé à
tous ceux qui avaient été pris par le
cuisinier cirque y revenez pas elle se
débat est là elle peut affecter le
cuisinier ou un client et c'est comme ça
que ça se passait la consommation de la
viande cuite elle ne va pas vous
infecter là on parle vraiment d'animaux
vivants qui transmettent ça devait être
aussi les déjections des animaux et cie
la cage
et pas nettoyé régulièrement et ses
déjections elles peuvent contenir aussi
du virus dans ce nouveau corps d'un
virus on n'a pas identifié l'animal mais
on a fort soupçon pour le pangolin alors
j'ai pas si vous savez ce qu'est un pan
de la vouvoyer regarder les images sur
sur internet facilement
c'est un animal qui est la fourmilière
faut comme un terrain noir salon et et
puis ça va ça monde des fourmis et c'est
un petit animal
et puis là il est recouvert décarie
comme un tatoo donc c'est un truc assez
improbable à le pangolin c'est très
mignon très gentil 120 personnes
malheureusement ces braconniers
parce qu'il ya des gens qui aiment
manger l'opano là ou alors qu'ils font
d'habitude traditionnelle avec les
écailles de pangolin et c'est un animal
protégé d'ailleurs le troisième samedi
de février chaque année vous le savez
pas mais c'est la journée vous dire a
dit paul golain et c'était 15 février
vous avez raté les prochaines pensez-y
et pourquoi parce que c'est un animal à
qui il faudrait foute la paix pour le
laisser vivre tranquille là où il était
et ça nous aurait évité beaucoup de
problèmes parce qu'aujourd'hui on sait
on a retrouvé chez les pangolins des
virus très proche de ce nouveau quand un
virus et qu'on pense que c'est le
pangolin qu'il après simplement transmis
à l'homme
avant il y avait peut-être une
chauve-souris 1 comme souvent d'ailleurs
un même pour ebola aussi à une chauve
souris qui a un peu l'ancêtre le virus
de départ c'est le réservoir
et puis le passage à l'homme il fait
parce qu'on appelle à notre
intermédiaire qui pour le sras c'était
la civette pour ce nouveau camp n'avait
russe se répandre
certains animaux ne devrait pas être
consommé tout simplement c'est qu'on a
vu des vidéos tout au début justement
quand le virus s'est développée en chine
où qui l'interpellait sur les réseaux
sociaux voire défaut d'une chauve-souris
dans une assiette et c est ce que c'est
et chaude ça oui je pense que voilà les
animaux sauvages et saurez où ils sont
et deux tiers des nouveaux virus qui
nous arrive nous via des animaux etc
dans ces cas là les conséquences sont
dévastatrices et puis franchement je
pense qu'on peut se passer du pont de là
où
ou de la civette il ya retard alors en
chine ils ont pris des mesures là
maintenant ils ont déjà avec le strass
est déjà interdit la consommation si
belle mais là je pense que c'est un des
mesures qui vont être beaucoup plus
générale sur la consommation de beaucoup
d'animaux sauvages dans les marchés
parce qu'il se rend compte que le coût
humain et économique est considérable
on parle depuis près d'un an de la crise
d urgence en france qu'on a couvert
régulièrement sur mundo travers des
manifestations les actions on leur a
donné la parole
souvent on nous évoque voilà le manque
de moyens au quotidien pour venir en
aide aux patients dans leurs missions
tous les jours ou disons il ya des
patients dans les brancards et c'est
quand on entend ces témoignages là on se
dit mais est ce que la france elle est
vraiment prête à une épidémie ou plus
encore il ya la question se pose alors
la question les conditions sont vraiment
difficiles à saab ont je suis moi j'y
travaille pas dans l'urgence je suis
chercheur dans un labo etc
mais j'ai beaucoup de collègues médecins
j'étais médecin de formation avant de
devenir chercheur et les conditions sont
difficiles mais chaque année les
urgences et les hôpitaux il gère les
épidémies de grippe chez les enfants
c'est des bronchiolites zafy se
respiratoires peuvent être sévères et
qui encombre les urgences aussi donc
pour ce nouveau quand un virus il ya un
gros travail de préparation qui est fait
il ya quand même une action coordonnée
pour se dire comment est ce qu'on va
faire si la l'épidémie s'amplifie pour
arrivé à prendre en charge les patients
tant qu'on reste sur un nombre de cas
relativement limité il y a un certain
nombre d'hôpitaux dédiée hier ils
étaient 38 ils sont passés à soixante
dix avec débit équipée d chambre à
pression négative circulaire n'en
ressort pas et donc on peut recevoir ces
patients parce qu'il ya pas de risque de
contamination à l'extérieur et tout ça
se gèlera
bien à partir du moment où la
coordination se fait proprement
il y aura beaucoup de mesures quand elle
d'hygiène très stick la prend dans ses
hôpitaux parce que des personnes
assurées liens sont à risque et puis les
autres patients aussi peuvent être à
risque après la partie qui sera plus
compliqué c'est si vraiment on se
retrouve devant une épidémie d'ampleur
beaucoup plus important je prendrai même
le cas de ce qui se passe en italie là
il se retrouve avec 300 cas on quelques
jours sur une province du nord est et là
la gestion de tout ça va devenir plus
compliqué il y a une étape qui a déjà
été franchie en italie et que d'autres
pays pratiquent déjà et qu'on pourrait
être amenée à pratiquer ans pense si
l'épidémie se développe en france qui
serait aussi de dire aux gens finalement
ce que vous avez c'est pas très
différent d'une grippe
et quand on a une grippe classique mais
on reste chez soi et donc on pourrait
proposer aux gens de rester chez soi et
tant qu'ils n'ont pas de symptôme majeur
le généraliste pourrait
ce
voir avec les faire le suivi de ces
patients là à part tout moment où il est
bien protégé
une question que je me pose d'ailleurs
mais l'âge de ma pratique clinique n'est
pas assez développée mais je me dis
est-ce que simplement avec une vision
j'ai dernier devrait pas faire une
consultation à distance parce que qu'est
ce qui est important c'est de voir la
fréquence avec laquelle le patient
respire attend qu'il ait pas essoufflé
et peut-être que finalement il va pas si
mal enfin là je m'avance mais c'est
peut-être des solutions comme ça qu'il
faudra envisager pour les gens qui ont
des formes bénignes parce que beaucoup
de gens et ça c'est quand même quelque
chose qu'il faut bien retenir plus de
80% des gens ils vont faire des formes
parfaitement bénigne il ya les 20% qui
vont faire des pneumonies plus marquée
qui auront besoin d'être hospitalisé et
puis paris cela est une proportion plus
faible heureusement qui font des formes
vraiment sévère et qui devront aller en
rien donc il ya un moment si on se
retrouvait beaucoup de cas on y est
parent mais ça pourrait arriver où là on
pourrait passer un et ça c'est ce qui
est en discussion actuellement quitte en
préparation actuellement à une nouvelle
façon de gérer les patients qui serait
de dire
aiguillon des patients selon la nature
des soins dont ils ont besoin les plus
sévères en réa les moyens sévère ils
sont allés d'inspiration classique pour
être surveillés de près et passer en ré
assises ont besoin mais à grande
majorité des personnels resteront à
domicile parce que finalement c'est un
virus qui heureusement dans la grande
majorité des cas et bénin et comme pour
une grippe classique vous restez chez
vous n'allez pas être hospitalisée pour
une grippe classique
je réponds à un commentaire pas c'est
quelqu'un qui veut vicat neuf cas a
déclaré dans sa région c'est pas quelque
chose d'officiel
les informations qu'on a ce soir je les
rappelle lé moitié déclarent aux en
tueur de 19 heures ces cas il y avait
douze personnes qui avaient été
hospitalisés depuis le début il n'y
avait plus aucun cas déclarés parce que
les personnes était guéri et à une
personne qui était décédé c'est sa
croissance en france et donc deux
nouveaux cas de contamination donc
annoncé ce soir là par lg robot
simplement en conférence de presse
l'un qui est hospitalisée à paris qui
renaît de chine est une personne qui est
hospitalisé en auvergne rhône à bhl
rhône alpes qui est une personne qui
revenait d'un séjour en lombardie
dans le nord de l'italie ce donc ces
deux personnes sont hospitalisées ce
soir on sait qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
personnes dont il ya des vérifications
qu'ils sont en couple parfois des
alertes info guy tombe dernière
régionaux mais ça veut pas dire que ce
sont des cas avérés ce sont des cas qui
sont en cours de vérification
et c'est ensuite qu'on sait si oui ou
non ils sont pas porteurs du coran un
virus et cette question qui se pose
parce qu'il ya les termes aussi de se
dire épidémie pandémie c'est quoi la
différence alors une part des billets
c'est une épidémie qui est sur au moins
deux continents donc aujourd'hui
labourdine radiatif clairement qu'à une
épidémie qui est celle de chine
et puis ailleurs ya des foyers
voilà c'est comme ça que le ms le
qualifie l oms jusqu'à récemment
c'est toujours bien gardé de parler de
pandémie ce qui voudrait dire qu'il ya
une épidémie qui s'est développée sur un
continent autre que l'asie je pense
qu'ils sont en train de se rendre compte
que là il ya un moment il va falloir
dire le mot pandémie l'épidémie en chine
des devient vraiment consistante
d'orchies pardon en italie devient
vraiment important de dire que c'est un
foyer basse à des prix tellement la
route si on dépasse les 300 cas ça va
être la même chose dans d'autres donc
voilà on est en train d'évoluer là
dessus mais par définition une pandémie
c'est une épidémie qui touche au moins
deux continents alors entreprendre
encore une ou deux questions les
commentaires avant de conclure cela mais
de parler aux sites des gestes pratiques
on a évoqué beaucoup mais comment éviter
une saturation aussi au niveau des
services d'urgence l'appel au 15 on sait
que une multiplication par 3 ou 4 des
appels comment éviter la saturation
c'est en souvenir de rien
moindre symptôme ces cas beaucoup de
craintes ya beaucoup de peur comment on
peut réussir à garder des gestes
rationnelle face à la crainte et la peur
légitime alors il ya des sites
d'information qui sont bien faire si
vous allez sur le site du ministère de
la santé vous trouverez plein d'infos
sur avec des questions réponses etc et
qui vous donne des indications sur le
sol au diagnostic
vous avez on l'a dit un numéro vert 1
que vous appelez nous vos questions en a
pris mal qu'un si vous avez des
questions à poser un appeler le 15 si
vraiment vous vous pensez malade est
vraiment malade
la difficulté c'est sûr c'est qu'à
partir du moment où l'historique d'un
voyage récent en chine ne sera plus
suffisamment indicatif pour dire vous
avez une forte suspicion de grands
navires us parce que le virus sera à
circuler ailleurs et bien les gens vont
avoir de plus de crainte d'être même
atteint mais rappelons le pour l'instant
le virus circule en france et circulent
très peu je leur ai dit le gouvernement
est très transparent le vram tous dès
que des points presse on fait tous les
jours les comptes sont d'année donc ya
pas de okacha rien là dessus de ce que
je connais en tout cas en revanche c'est
vrai des semaines qui viennent il va y
avoir de plus en plus introduction du
virus et
et donc voilà on va de plus en plus
sollicitée est mis à l'épreuve pour des
confirmations diagnostic le pire est à
venir
alors le pire c'est là où il faut un peu
se essayer de se projeter sur qu'est ce
que ça ferait contre 1 je dis pas qu'on
va arriver là dessus mais admettons que
dans les semaines qui viennent
face à l'épidémie généralistes ya
plusieurs foyers qui vont s'allumer dans
les semaines qui viennent et puis qui
vont finalement je dirais presque
confluer et on se retrouve avec une
situation où on a un nombre de
diagnostics chaque jour très élevé
d'abord on va se rendre compte qu'il ya
beaucoup de formes bénignes et de plus
en plus un pour l'instant on dit qui à
20% de pneumonie 85 forme bénigne qui
peuvent rester chez eux en gros et la
mortalité c'est important de tout ça on
va se rendre compte bientôt qui a encore
plus de forme tellement peu
symptomatiques les gens vont même pas
consulté et puis ya même des gens qui
n'ont aucun symptôme en italie dans le
compte qu'ils ont actuellement deux des
nouveaux cas il ya énormément de gens
qui n'ont aucun symptôme
donc on va se rendre compte fidèlement
cette maladie n'est peut-être pas si
grave que ça et puis on se retrouvera
dans une situation de ce que
j'appellerais une épidémie de grippe
assez banal finalement
avec quand même quelques réserves
d'abord on ne sait même pas où j'ai dit
ah quand même la proportion de formes de
dessin on en retrouve quand même 1 %
chez les moins de 60 ans ça c'est plus
qu'une grippe saisonnière classique et
puis on est
habitué à on connaît la grippe a
finalement ils vont la banalise
d'ailleurs des gens se vaccinent pas ce
qui me donne beaucoup de gens qui
devraient être vaccinés qui le font pas
mais les morts de la grippe c'est des
morts qui sont très indirecte ce que
j'entends par là c'est que ça va être
des personnes âgées qui vont faire une
décompensation d'une bronchite chronique
d'un afin qu'ils vont faire la fortune
du bio carte jeune homme ça et la grippe
et des derrières ne le savaient pas là
pour tous les cas on aura des musiques
vont arriver rue ce qui sera fait et
donc ça forcément ce sera un peu plus
anxiogène mais jeunes dans un scénario
qui serait le scénario le plus péjoratif
et une fois de plus c est un scénario
c'est pas du tout une réalité
aujourd'hui on peut imaginer qu'on se
retrouvera avec finalement comme une
épicerie beaucoup de gens touchés
la plupart resteront chez eux vont
guérir spontanément il n'y aura pas de
problème particulier
malheureusement une certaine fraction se
retrouvera à l'hôpital dont certains en
réanimation mais on apprendre à vivre
avec parce que on a une force
d'adaptation qu'on soupçonne pas qui
fait que quand on connaîtra mieux notre
ennemi et bien on saura le gérer et
vivre avec mais une banque puis cela je
vous parle d'un scénario qui est le
scénario le plus péjoratif
parce que c'est vrai que ce qui inquiète
beaucoup c'est de se dire et on voit
dans les commentaires au delà de
certaines personnes qui peuvent poser
des questions de se dire qu'on est à ce
soir c'est un chiffre en irak mais qui
peut toujours évoluer minute après
minute tellement la situation est
évolutive
on parle de 322 contamination l'italie
et 11 morts c'est quand même un
pourcentage très important de morts par
rapport au nombre de personnes
contaminées alors arriverait vraiment
deux camps a commencé datation vraiment
du début voir le profil des personnes
qui sont décédées le réel quand on voit
la vitesse avec laquelle on identifie
les nouveaux cas en italie dont beaucoup
une fois plus je répète souvent
asymptomatique autant les des seuils
s'impose à nous parce que ces gens là
ils ont été hospitalisés parce qu'ils
avaient des formes très sévère au temps
va peut-être découvrir qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de gens qui ont des formes mineures
et donc le proportion décès ne sera pas
à la fin ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui mais
mais mais plus faible parce que pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore fait le tour
de toutes les formes mineures qui existe
sous cette question qui reçoit un
commentaire d un rapport à la chine va
se dire est ce que les premiers jours
n'ont pas été de ne pas révéler
l'ampleur de ce qui se passait ce qui a
pas eu un décalage entre les premiers
cas détectés et véritable prise en
compte de l'urgence de la situation pour
alors la chine elle a été étonnante de
niveaux différents
sur la partie réalisation qui se passait
quelque chose d'anormal parce qu'il y
avait des patients dans une ville de
onze millions d'habitants qui étaient
tous liés aux mêmes marchés douran et il
te dira voilà là il ya quelque chose de
nouveau
la prise de conscience a été rapide elle
a mis l appliquer quelques médecins
chinois dont 1 malheureusement vous le
savez probablement pour beaucoup d'entre
vous est décédé depuis un et il ya eu
aussi donc à partir de là un isolement
de prélèvements sur des sécrétions
respiratoires qui ont permis
d'identifier un nouveau virus en un
temps absolument record et de
performances technologiques pour nous
dire le 10 janvier alors que les
premiers malades ont vraiment commencé à
arriver le 15 décembre moins d'un an
après voilà la séquence complète d'un
nouveau virus
c'était remarquable est important parce
que ce n'est pas la séquence de ce
nouveau virus
on a pu faire une thèse diagnostic qui
sont utilisés aujourd'hui partout dans
le monde
donc là ça a été très rapide en revanche
sur la description de tous ses premiers
quarts et
là la façon avec laquelle tout ça nous a
été rapporté nous disons au début qui
avait 40 cas qu'ils étaient tous liés au
marché où pratiquement tous nos marchés
d'animaux sans transmissions secondaires
avérés et donc probablement pas de
risque épidémique mais simplement des
gens qui avait été affecté par un virus
animal épices à s'arrêter là là je pense
que plus de transparence aurait été
utile à un moment où si une action
extrêmement énergique aurait peut-être
au tout début permis d'endiguer le
démarrage cette application et
commentaires quelqu'un qui me dit
peut-on développer des anticorps contre
le connacht coronavirus être à
s'immuniser toubib et c'est d'ailleurs
ce que vont faire la très grande très
grande majorité des gens
on va d'ailleurs en chine
il demande maintenant aux personnes
guéries de venir pour prendre leur faire
un don de sang dont on va recueillir le
plasma le plasma il contient des
anticorps et il pourra même être
injectés à des personnes en phase aiguë
de la maladie pour faire bénéficier à
cette personne des ordis corps d'une
personne qui a déjà guérie voilà alors
il ya quelqu'un qui nous demandent
comment sont gérées les personnes
décédées est ce qu'elles sont enterrés
ou incinérés fond vous savez
recommandations qui sont faites
d'ailleurs on est sur des c'est pas sur
des personnes décédées les sécrétions
respiratoires peuvent rester contagieuse
dans quelques temps il ya d'autres
fluides biologiques vous pourriez
éventuellement trouver le virus on le
gère comme des personnes qui sont
décédées de maladies infectieuses type
lip ou autre mais ya pas de
recommandations qui vont au delà comme
par exemple pour une maladie ebola etc
mais
après ça dépend des confessions
religieuses des choix des individus et
ces questions qui se posaient le virus
petite ville dans des zones chaudes est
ce que justement une température d'un
endroit à l'autre mais gimont et dans un
endroit il fait moins 10 les plus sujets
au moins sujet à la voie à ce qu'il ya
une valeur sûre un certain nombre de
récits virus respiratoires
on sait qu'ils ont une recrudescence en
période hivernale ça peut tenir à deux
facteurs certains ces virus vivent mieux
quand il fait froid et sec
vraisemblablement l'autre facteur qui
contribue beaucoup à la transmission des
virus respiratoires en période hivernale
c'est qu'en période hivernale les gens
vivent en atmosphères confinées beaucoup
plus proches les uns des autres et dont
la transmission des virus respiratoires
se fait plus facilement et ça donc les
deux facteurs viennent ensemble pour
expliquer pourquoi des épidémies
hivernales des virus respiratoires
maintenant sur ce corps d'un virus on
peut espérer peut-être quand il fera un
peu plus chaud m'a déjà les gens sont
moins les uns sur les autres
- de transmission est ce qu'il sera
sorti de la température on est quand
même au milieu intérieur il a énormément
de variation et puis rappelons nous il
ya gros navires us nous autres qui sévit
dans les pays du golfe a été responsable
d'une maladie qu'on appelle mer sans
middle east l'exploratrice andrew
celui-là il vit très bien 50 degrés les
questions dans les commentaires
on a parlé de la transmission animal
vers l'être humain mais est ce que ça
peut être l'enfer ceci dit ça pourrait
savourer savamment étudié à vasco des
plus inquiets de ce qui se passe de
l'ovaire l'animal mais il n'y a pas de
raisons physiologiques qui permet de
dire que des hommes ne pourraient pas
infecter des animaux après les virus
histoire assez spécifique d'une espèce
veut dire là c'est une panne de l'un et
pas tous les animaux qu'ils ont transmis
à chez nous il faut qu'ils soient
adaptés à son espèce
donc c'est pas tous les animaux et si
vous avez des animaux domestiques par
exemple on
pas de raison de penser que vous avez
affecter votre choix votre cher et c'est
avec ce nouveau quand un virus ou que ce
votre chat ou watch a pu servir de
vecteur lui furent un commentaire
peut-on coeur seul du virus c'est ce qui
se passe sur la majorité des gens alors
ils ont quand même un traitement qu'on
appelle symptomatique un rouleur si ce
qu'il ya ceux qui ont des formes très
bénigne ils vont gérer tout seul
celui qui ont des formes plus sévères
ils vont être un hôpital et puis là il y
aura les traitements dits symptomatique
qui vont les aider à passer la phase
aiguë et mme émond a effectivement pas
de traitement antiviral qui attaquent le
virus lui-même dont la majorité des gens
d'une certaine façon vont guérir
s'aperçoit que les maladies des poumons
au niveau des poumons à ce qu'ils sont
plus sujets aux sahraouis je pense que
toute pathologie préexistante des
poumons voix en plus vénérables à la
réconciliation sur le temps au niveau
d'un vaccin ce sera à peu près en deux
ans ce sera plein voilà il faut savoir
le vaccin ça prend du temps
le vaccin c'est important parce que dans
la santé publique c'est ce qui marche le
mieux quand il s'agit de contrôler une
maladie mais le développeur du vaccin
entre sa conception son test chez
l'animal et après le passage sur les
tests chez l'homme
ça va prendre à 2 ans minimum tiffany
qui mauvaise que ça peut se propager
dont l'eau pas de raison de penser dans
la zone le penser des scientifiques
analysant le virus ont remarqué qu'il y
avait des traces de création virus qu'en
pensez vous des traces de création art
je pense que je serai pas le dire
j'avais lu la question en même temps
voilà on regarde un peu les dernières
questions qui peut y avoir sur les
constructions d'hôpital assez rapide est
ce que c'est efficace est ce que c'est
peut-être campagne à quand vous avez
besoin de maladies données des patients
la difficulté qui s'est posé là bas
était le besoin d'isoler les patients
notamment ceux qui avaient des formes
relativement bénigne donc là ils ont
fait dans les stades et espaces de
grands dortoirs pour les gens qui ont
des formes bénignes mais il ya d'autres
pays qui choisissent d'isolement à
domicile qui est probablement et plus
plus adaptée mais en ce qui concerne les
plus faibles et fragiles peut-on et
protéger c'est l'idée peut-être de
limiter les déplacements
abbas est effectivement pour eux
peut-être le moins exposé possible ce
sont 101 alors ce qui est bien pour eux
déjà cet être vaccinés contre la grippe
ça alors les protège de la grippe qui
est quand même très importante et puis
ça veut dire précisant une fièvre on est
tout de suite beaucoup plus à même de
penser que sa place à de nouveaux
gradins virus je suis ge energy qu'à la
pénicilline wish plus à risque et non la
pénicilline viendrait si vous avez une
surinfection pulmonaire sa
d'antibiotiques qui agit sur les
bactéries pour qu'il peut y avoir dans
les maladies virales des surinfections
pulmonaires
après il ya d'autres classes
d'antibiotiques qui peuvent être
efficaces chez des gens qui ont des
allergies la finition on sait que
certains pays ont fermé les frontières
avec les rend en chine la france ne l'a
pas fait avec l'italie est ce que il y
aune qui pose cette question est à dire
les frontières et dhr et il a évité la
propagation
alors là on sait que deux
fermer les frontières ça peut ralentir
mais ça n'arrête jamais on gagne à peu
de temps mais alors le coût économique
de fermeture de frontières est
absolument considérable et c'est pour ça
que les pays de l'espace schengen ont
décidé de ne pas fermer leurs frontières
l'a ironiquement la vitalité le pays qui
avait arrêté ses relations de vol avec
la chine c'était le seul pays qui
avaient arrêté ça et c'est pourtant chez
eux que l'épidémie à démarré question
toto qui veulent tout simplement quand
serons-nous en quarantaine sur paris
alors est-ce que ça risque d'arriver est
ce que c'est possible si tu pars en
quarantaine sur l'ensemble de la
capitale et ses compagnes et il peut y
avoir des foyers qui démarre et paris
est une très grande ville avec beaucoup
des changes après il y aura différentes
gradation de mesures à prendre qui vont
de ce qu'on avait dit déjà pour tout le
monde et dès maintenant les mesures
d'hygiène de base
après on pourrait être arrivé à des
mesures ou on vous recommande de faire
du télétravail les enfants puissent ne
pas aller à l'école ou pas etc
bayram toute une série de choses qui
vont être faits la ville elle même
complètement avec un cordon sanitaire
autour de ça on y réfléchit pas et cette
question est ce que le fait de résider
projet d'hôpital et plus inquiétant que
d'habiter en pleine campagne cette
question pratique nous verrons pour
atteindre un catch attack et qu'ils
n'ont plus les asthmatiques personnes
souffrant de problèmes respiratoires
sont ils plus à risque je n'ai pas de
donner là dessus mais je dirais
vraisemblablement oui les pathologies
cardiaques aussi je dirais aussi c'est
comme pour la grippe à un cdd que vous
avez une affection pulmonaire
grave et ben vous des compensées ce type
de maladies de d'affection général
voilà je pense qu'on va confirmer que
tout doucement trévières soit la journée
et pour certains d'entre nous peut en
effet pas ce que c'est que vous êtes et
qui va continuer encore très sollicités
pour vous je pensais au niveau de
l'institut pasteur vos interventions
médiatiques c'est quoi l'idée c'est
d'essayer de faire de la pédagogie reste
que je pense que c'est très important
parce qu'il faut le virus ouvrage je
pense qu'on va avoir effectivement comme
on la dit de plus en plus de cas dans
les semaines à venir il faut accompagner
sa forte expliqué aux gens c'est les
règles sur disproportionnée et
inappropriée qui sont quelquefois les
plus dangereuses donc on fait beaucoup
de sa brutale est logique mais à côté on
fait beaucoup de recherches aussi bien
donc il faut savoir que les journées
pour nous elle commence depuis un mois à
6 7 heures le matin elles finissent à
une heure le soir et on associe plein de
choses entrent d'abord notre à votre
recherche
le diagnostic un qui fait un masque
pasteur au sein d'un seul 2 des virus et
mouz avia qu'avec l'élévation et 9 qui
travaillent l'avoir ici même sur le pont
depuis tout dégusté les premières des
diagnostics pour la france et qui ont pu
identifier tous les premiers patients
français
et puis après tout le travail de
recherche parce qu'on est sur des
traitements on est sur des packs ça on
est sûr tout ça parce qu'on considère
que c'est extrêmement apporteront leur
cellier moment qui pour nous sont à la
fois extrêmement excitant parce que
c'est un virus on essaie de comprendre
on n'est pas des scientifiques ça après
je vous cache pas que là on est
préoccupés parce qu'on voit que on
savait que ça allait arriver puis
maintenant ça y est tu légitime s'il
était légitime mais une fois de plus je
pense que on est capable de s'adapter et
est très difficile de dire quelle sera
l'ampleur
de l'épidémie en france il ya une
épidémie ou est ce qu'il restera que
quelques foyers isolés mais on s'y
prépare en tout cas certainement
et puis au jour le jour parce qu'il faut
savoir être flexible pour s'adapter
il y avait tellement de questions
faut-il vendre toutes ses actions cotées
en bourse sera pas y répond par go je
suis pas de bonnes je suis pas la bonne
invités mais mais mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya aussi mon voix sur les marchés
économiques et depuis quelques jours un
impact assez important avec une baisse
très importante au niveau des départs
sera peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
mais dans un autre lac parce que ce
n'était pas le sujet aujourd'hui et avec
à d'autres invités voilà exactement
on a essayé en tout cas de répondre au
maximum de questions possibles on va
vous remercier d'avoir été aussi
nombreux à suivre ce direct à avoir
commenté partager bien évidemment si on
pouvait répondre à toutes les questions
individuellement je pense qu'on aurait
fini jody d'un masque on l'apprend à la
baisse et c'est pas si longtemps que ça
c'était quelques heures quelques heures
dont il faut le renouveler il faut les
renouveler tout s'est compliqué des
masses car il faut bien les manipuler
ses traces et pas mais c'est pas une
solution dans l'immédiat le masque pour
l'instant le virus circule pas et
travaillent compagnie rappelez-vous 1
c'est le matthieu ricard
le plus simple pour ce qu'ils ont été
de retour d'un pays à risque ou contact
avec la patience ils ont des symptômes
équipe ans est malade pour protéger leur
entourage
le fameux masque filtrant est fait mais
de et où ce serait seulement si le virus
se fait à circuler beaucoup et si vous
étiez à mener aller dans des zones très
densément peuplées là il aurait
dernièrement parce que la famille
endeuillée par les femmes enceintes
est ce qu'un plus vulnérables pour
toutes les maladies mais on n'a pas de
données là dessus je conclus avec ces
dernières informations vont vous
remercier jean baptiste j'ai varié qui
le secrétaire d'état aux transports a
invité ce soir les français à reporter
leur voyage vers les zones d'italie
contaminés on parle de la toscana sicile
là les jurys la lombardie et la vénétie
qui sont des zones donc où il ya des
détecter et ont donc les français sont
invités à reporter leur voyage chez les
informations pratiques qu'on vous donne
ce soir qui a des zones de confinement
en cours de nouveaux cas détectés de
coronavirus c'est ce qu'on évoquait au
début de ce direct et c'est
l'information de la soirée 1 à paris et
une autre personne dans le rhône alpes
pour le cas à paris c'est une personne
qui est venue de chine le 7 février
dernier pour la personne dans le rhône
alpes auvergne rhône-alpes c'est
quelqu'un qui revient du nord de
l'italie le bilan qui est passé ce soir
à onze morts des victimes âgée et très
âgées parce qu'elles sont âgés de 84 91
83 et 76 ans selon le commissaire angelo
borelli de la protection civile locale
qui a évoqué cela on était à sept décès
il ya encore quelques heures on est à
onze ce soir est un peu plus de 300 cas
recensés
un hôtel en autriche a été placé en
quarantaine en fin d'après midi et vous
évoquez dans les commentaires courbevoie
ce ne sont pas des cas détectés ce sont
des cas des suspects voilà c'est à dire
que possible enfin le premier truc
suspect s'est on se pose la question
possible il ya bien un interrogatoire
avec le régulateur du 15 qui dit a
effectivement il ya une vraie
possibilité on va vous testez et puis
confirmer ou infirmer ensuite voilà donc
là c'est des vérifications et rien ne
dit c'est important de le dire
en tout cas je tiens à vous remercier
ballon tous les internautes qui ont
suivi ce soir
mais bon elle était très content de
venir vous voir est bon on essaiera de
refaire ça je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion
voilà on la salue de ses beaux-frères
flexible qui tape sur ce direct on a
dirigé ce personnage
en tout cas on vous remercie encore
toutes et tous sans vous remercie en
frontal et chapelles que vous êtes
épidémiologistes donc à l'institut
pasteur
ça consiste en quoi concrètement eh bien
on s'intéresse aux épidémies et on
travaille beaucoup sur tout ce qui est
mode de transmission origines des virus
parce que je travaille beaucoup sur les
virus et puis quelques fois aussi les
complications pour les personnes
affectées et ben très bonne soirée à
vous et très bonne soirée à ceux qui
n'ont rien je coupe le live tout de
suite et vous pouvez retrouver en
quelques instants le replay on a abordé
toutes ces questions pour ceux qui
n'auraient peut-être pas eu la réponse à
leurs questions on l'a parfois border
avant dans le live et vous pourrez donc
voir le replay avec de nombreuses
questions qu'on a abordé mais bien
évidemment la rédaction brut restent
mobilisés avec de nombreux sujets à
venir une couverture manière quasi
quotidienne mais presque pour vous devez
les dernières informations sur ce qui se
passe avec des sujets pédagogie des
directs et autres pour vous donner
toutes les informations sur ce qui se
passe et répond à vos questions à vos
inquiétudes légitimes et j'espère qu'on
a pu répondre à une partie de celle-ci
ce soir avec vous en tout cas très très
bonne soirée à vous et on se retrouve
très très vite sur route au coeur de
l'actualité
n'hésitez pas à nous suivre suivent la
page facebook de brut me retrouver sur
l'ensemble des réseaux sociaux brut
officielle sur instagram snapshot
twitter activer les notifications direct
comme ça lors des prochains direct que
ce soit sans coronavirus ou d'autres
événements vous serez directement sur le
live et pour ceux qui souhaitent de
suivre vous avez mon compte en
descriptions cela ghrib is in phone
retrouve également sur l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux twitter instagram harry
been comme vous l'avez en orthographe
sur le compte qui est identifié dans ce
live merci à vous très bonne soirée chez
lui baptiste à la modération et j
réduction brute et qui ont fait remonter
vos commentaires et qui ont mis quelques
commentaires important ce soir pour vous
donner des informations utiles sur le
numéro vert sur les informations données
par le ministère de la santé très bonne
soirée à vous et très bonne soirée à
vous encore waouh